Hallo, ich bin Peter Adamson, willkommen zurück zu
Denkerinnen in der Antike im
Mittelalter. Dies ist der letzte Vortrag, und
wir werden über
Christine de Pizan und ihre Reaktion
auf böse Frauenfeindlichkeit sprechen, bevor ich auf das
Thema des heutigen Vortrags eintauche I  Ich wollte nur
ein paar Leuten danken, die diese
ganze Reihe von Vorlesungen möglich gemacht haben, also meinen
Kollegen am King's College London und
insbesondere in der philosophischen Fakultät
, die die Diskussionen
über die Durchführung dieser Reihe von Vorlesungen angestoßen haben. Ich bin
ihnen sehr dankbar
LMU München und besonders an Eric
Kenneth, den Mann hinter der Kamera, der
auch die ganze Postproduktionsarbeit an
den Videos gemacht hat und sie so fantastisch aussehen lässt,
also danke für deine
technische Zauberei gleich heute in der
letzten Vorlesung, zu der wir gehen werden  Schauen
wir uns Christine de Pizan an, und ich werde
Ihnen ein wenig über sie erzählen, und dann werden
wir uns eine Art
Kontext mittelalterlicher Einstellungen gegenüber Frauen
ansehen, der eigentlich nichts ist  Darüber haben wir
noch viel gesprochen, aber wir werden sehen,
dass es auf einige der alten
Einstellungen gegenüber Frauen zurückgeht, insbesondere bei
Aristoteles, die wir zu Beginn dieser Vortragsreihe besprochen haben,
und dann werden
wir sehen, wie Christine darauf reagiert hat
mittelalterliche Haltungen und insbesondere
frauenfeindliche Texte, also Texte
, die kritisch über
Frauen oder sogar ziemlich schäbige und
wirklich feindselige Aussagen über die
Ehe über die sexuellen Praktiken
und Wünsche von Frauen und so weiter zu sagen haben, lassen Sie mich
Ihnen zunächst etwas sagen  allgemeinere
informationen über christine tatsächlich mit ihr gingen
wohl über die offiziellen
chronologischen grenzen dieser
vortragsreihe hinaus, weil ich denke, dass die meisten
leute sie nicht als
mittelalterliche figur bezeichnen würden, wenn man normalerweise
als renaissancefigur angesehen würde, und
das macht sinn, wenn  Sie lebte bis weit
ins 15. Jahrhundert hinein, und die Texte, die
wir uns besonders ansehen werden,
wurden um 1400 geschrieben, obwohl h  Ihre
Schriftstellerkarriere ging danach mehrere
Jahrzehnte weiter und sie lebte
zuerst in Italien, dann in Frankreich, schrieb hauptsächlich auf
Französisch, also ist sie eine weitere Frau
, die in der Umgangssprache schreibt
und in viele der typischen Genres
des Schreibens involviert ist, die wir mit der
Renaissance verbinden, wenn auch nur mit einigen  von ihnen
existierten bereits im Mittelalter, also wäre ein gutes
Beispiel dafür ihr
Beitrag zur Tradition der
sogenannten Spiegel für Fürsten.
Hier schreibt eine gelehrte Philosophin
ein Ratgeberwerk für einen politischen Herrscher, und
sie schrieb mehrere Werke wie dieses
einschließlich eines für den Enkel von
Karl V., dem König von Frankreich, eigentlich war
Karl V. selbst eine wichtige
Figur in Christines Leben, weil sie
an seinem Hof aufgewachsen war. Sie war die Tocht
r einer wichtigen Person an seinem Hof,
lso
ächst sie als gut ausge
ildete Aristokratin auf  was erklärt, warum
sie so beeindruckende
Beiträge zur Literatur des späten 14. und
besonders des frühen 15. Jahrhunderts leisten konnte
Dieser Spiegelspiegel für Fürsten
, den ich das Buch des
Friedens beschreibe, legt sie ihre Gedanken über
Tugend besonders dar und welche Rolle sie
im politischen Leben spielt, und sie schrieb über andere
politische Themen - einschließlich der Kriegsführung, die sie
als eine Art autobiografisches Werk
bezeichnete  Vision und vielleicht am
bekanntesten schrieb sie Werke zur Verteidigung
der Ehre und Tugend von Frauen, einschließlich
eines wirklich erstaunlichen Textes mit dem Titel Die Stadt der
Damen, der
das Projekt, das sie, wie ich sage,
um 1400 begann, als sie anregte und dann daran
teilnahm, irgendwie verwirklichte  Debatte über ein
bestimmtes mittelalterliches Gedicht namens
Romance of the Rose, in dem ein Liebhaber gezeigt wird,
wie er eine Reihe von
Personifikationen wie Eifersucht und den
Freund trifft, die mit diesem Liebhaber interagieren
und dem Liebhaber Ratschläge zur Eroberung
seiner Geliebten geben, und die Geliebte wird hier
als symbolisiert  Rose, und der Grund, warum
Christine sich für diesen Text interessierte oder
eigentlich über diesen Text empört war, ist, dass er,
wie wir sehen werden, Passagen hat  darin,
die extrem frauenfeindlich sind, also
gehen wir irgendwann in
diesem Vortrag hin. Zuerst möchte ich Ihnen ein
wenig über
ihre politischen Schriften erzählen, und ich dachte, ich
konzentriere mich auf diese Arbeit, das Buch des
Friedens, so wie ich es sage  es ist ein sogenannter
Fürstenspiegel, das heißt,
sie gibt einem Herrscher oder einem
angehenden Herrscher in diesem Fall eines
jungen Mannes Ratschläge, und sie spricht darüber, wie man am
besten Erfolg in der politischen
Herrschaft erzielt, und hier kann man vielleicht wirklich sehen,
warum man  könnte dies als eine Art
Renaissance-Projekt betrachten, da es im Mittelalter auch Marys vier Prinzen gab, also gibt es
zum Beispiel ein sehr
berühmtes von jemandem namens Giles of Rome, einem
Schüler von Thomas von Aquin, aber einige
der Dinge, die Christine sagt  scheinen
eine viel berühmtere
Renaissance-Autorin vorwegzunehmen, die in diesem Genre schreibt,
nämlich Machiavelli, weil
sie immer wieder an
das Eigeninteresse des Herrschers appelliert, also ist das,
was sie sagt, im Grunde nicht so
ganz
offensichtlich sollte der Herrscher gerecht und
gut sein, und so sahen Gerechtigkeit und
Güte aus, was sie sagt,
ist, dass der Herrscher gerecht und
gut sein muss, um ein erfolgreicher Herrscher zu sein,
also lassen Sie mich Ihnen ein Beispiel aus diesem
Texas geben, das von ihr stammt  Nehmen Sie an,
dass die Menschen sich mit einem Herrn wiederfinden, der ihnen
mit seinen Kriegen und Forderungen
viel Schaden zugefügt hat, indem er
die Brüder oder Eltern ihrer Söhne, ihrer Kinder,
enterbt und sie selbst enterbt und das
Land zerstört hat, und nehmen Sie an,
dass sie geneigt sind, dies fortzusetzen
Wahnsinn und dass sie in allen Regionen
wegen ihm gehasst und angesprochen werden und dazu verdammt sind, niemals
ohne Krieg zu sein, und angenommen, dass seine
Sturheit immer schlimmer anhält,
fragte ich Sie, ob diese Leute und alle
Adligen gegen einen solchen Herrn rebelliert haben,
angesichts dessen, dass sie  würde sich so unterdrückt
und bis zum Äußersten getrieben fühlen wäre es
überraschend und offensichtlich ist der Punkt nein
wäre nicht überraschend mit anderen Worten,
sie ist hier ansprechend  nicht zu den Fürsten, die das
Gefühl haben, dass er ein aufrechter
Mensch oder moralisch gerecht sein sollte,
sagt sie, wenn Sie weiterhin
Krieg führen können,
wenn Sie ungerechte Steuern
usw  Sie können mit Aufständen
rechnen, von denen Sie erwarten können, dass sie möglicherweise gestürzt werden. Das ist
also ein sehr direkter Appell an das
Eigeninteresse des Prinzen und nicht an
eine Art erhabenes moralisches Ideal
Im Text des Buches des
Friedens heißt es, dass der Prinz erfolgreich werden wird, indem er den Frieden bewahrt und
allgemein ein tugendhafter Herrscher
ist, und daher
beinhaltet ein Großteil des Textes,
die verschiedenen Tugenden durchzugehen, die der Prinz haben
könnte, und zu erklären, worauf sie
hinauslaufen, also hier ein weiterer  Passage aus
den Texten und sie zitiert Cicero hier
am Anfang, was
uns vielleicht auch an ein erstes
typisches Renaissance-Angebot denken lässt
Cicero zitiert Figuren aus der Antike und sagt,
nichts sei angenehmer oder geeigneter
, geliebt zu werden als die Tugend, und Seneca schenkt in seinem
Brief an die seltsame Tugend der Knochen
dauerhafte Freude, und Aristoteles beweist
die Wahrheit, dass in der Tugend jede
Freude liegt, seit es Ruhm und unvermischte Wonne gibt
Nicht im Hören von etwas
Veränderlichem kann es keine wahre Glückseligkeit geben, außer
wenn die Dinge ein so hohes Maß
an Güte und Stabilität besitzen, dass sie
nicht durch irgendeine Art von Störung beschädigt oder verunsichert werden können
, und was
in Gottes Namen auf einer so hohen Ebene steht, ist
nur Tugend  nichts anderes,
oh edler Prinz, wenn du nur wüsstest, dass
das Gute ihr Ende umfasst
, würdest du sicherlich keinen anderen Schatz so
sehr wünschen wie die Tugend, denn sie allein kann dich
groß, mächtig, reich, berühmt, gefürchtet und
geliebt machen, so wie ich sage, das ist eine
interessante Passage darin  Auf verschiedene Arten,
so wie ich gerade erwähnt habe, zeigt es, wie
sie ist, dass die Art von Angeboten
, auf die sie zurückgreift, dort erwähnt wird
Seneca Cicero Aristoteles besonders unter
Verwendung der Seneca und Cicero ist sehr
typisch für den Humanismus der Renaissance. Dies
waren bereits zwei Lieblingsautoren zum
Beispiel des Autors Petrarca aus dem 14. Jahrhundert
, der
als Vater des Humanismus gilt
und dessen Vorwahlen und Vorlieben in der
asiatischen Literatur getroffen werden  Von anderen
Humanisten, einschließlich Christine de
Pizan, könnte man sie als
Ministerin selbst beschreiben. Die Idee, dass sie
Machiavelli vorwegnimmt, kommt meiner Meinung nach
besonders in dieser letzten Zeile
zum Ausdruck, also die Idee, dass Tugend Sie nicht
nur geliebt, sondern auch gefürchtet machen kann, also wissen Sie das vielleicht
Ich bin nicht Kentucky, aber es war berühmt
dafür zu sagen, sollte der Prinz besser
geliebt oder gefürchtet werden, um erfolgreich zu regieren,
und er sagt beides, aber wenn
Sie sich entscheiden müssen, sollten Sie befürchtet werden, nicht
geliebt zu werden. Christine würde sich wahrscheinlich
eher für geliebt als für gefürchtet entscheiden  Beachten Sie, dass
sie sagt, Sie sollten sich für beides entscheiden.
Vielleicht bemerken Sie in dieser Passage auch, dass
es definitiv philosophi geworden ist  cal
Grundlage sogar eine metaphysische Grundlage für das, was
sie sagt, weil sie argumentiert, dass
das, was wir im Leben anstreben sollten, und ich
meine, hier spricht sie über den Prinzen,
aber ich schätze, sie würde für alle,
was wir im Leben anstreben sollten, Güter sein
, die unzerstörbar und unzerstörbar sind  dauerhaft
und dann identifiziert sie eine Tugend als
das dauerhafteste Gut, das wir suchen können, also
sollten wir wirklich danach streben
, um Glück zu erlangen, und das
klingt fast wie ein platinistisches
Argument für Tugend, obwohl es in gewisser Weise
etwas ist, das in andere passen würde
philosophische Schulen wie die Stoiker
zum Beispiel, weil die Herden
auch sagen würden, dass die Tugend in gewissem Sinne
unzerstörbar ist, denn ob du
tugendhaft bist oder nicht, liegt bei dir
und unterliegt nicht der Art des Zufalls
und Zufalls der Welt um dich herum
diese Tugend  Es geht wirklich darum, wie Sie
auf die Welt reagieren, es geht nicht darum,
wie die Welt ist. Wenn wir also in gewisser
Weise stabiler sind als so etwas wie
Wohlstand oder Gesundheit w  Das kann einem jederzeit genommen werden
, es ist
eigentlich nicht so sehr ein Thema, das
wir mit Aristoteles in Verbindung bringen würden, obwohl sie
Aristoteles zitiert, scheint dies wirklich so,
dass sie eher wie eine
Renaissance-Philosophin denkt, die sie
wie eine Philosophin denkt, die am meisten
beeinflusst ist  Hellenistische Philosophie, wie
sie von Seneca und Cicero vertreten wird,
spiele ich in dieser Philosophie, es gibt
andere interessante Themen, und ihre
politischen Arbeiten, denke ich,
stammen aus dem Text, in dem
sie über Kriegsführung spricht, weil sie
in gewissem Maße von traditionellen
mittelalterlichen Vorstellungen darüber abweicht, wie  Kriegsführung ist
so oft gerechtfertigt, dass die Mittelalter
sagen würden, dass Kriegsführung
nur dann gerechtfertigt ist, wenn es sich um Selbstverteidigung handelt.
Selbst die Kreuzzüge wurden gerechtfertigt,
indem sie als Fall von
Selbstverteidigung dargestellt wurden, was irgendwie
seltsam klingt, wie das Aufbrechen
von Europa  und ins Heilige Land zu gehen
und zu versuchen, die islamischen Mächte dort zu vertreiben,
wie stellt das einen Fall von dar
Selbstverteidigung Nun,
die Idee wäre, dass das Heilige
Land rechtmäßig der christlichen
Gemeinschaft gehört und dass es effektiv
von den Muslimen überfallen und dieser Gemeinschaft zu Unrecht weggenommen wurde, und daher
zählen wir eine Selbstverteidigung, um sie zurückzufordern, wenn Sie
zurückkehren  So gibt Christine eine
ziemlich andere Denkweise darüber an,
wie Kriegsführung zu rechtfertigen ist, nämlich dass
Kriegsführung nicht so sehr durch die
Ziele des Krieges oder das, was manchmal
als Casus Belli bezeichnet wird, gerechtfertigt ist, so dass der Grund, warum
Krieg überhaupt erklärt wird
, relevant ist  Aber wirklich entscheidend war,
ob die Entscheidung, in den Krieg zu ziehen,
auf angemessene Weise getroffen wurde, also
handelt es sich um die Könige, die nur
eine Art monarchische
Regierung übernehmen. Dies beinhaltet, dass der König den
Rat seines Kabinetts und seiner Beratergruppe
einholt und die Entscheidung rational erwägt
in den Krieg ziehen und wenn das Recht
auf ein Beruhigungsverfahren, mit dem der
Krieg eingeleitet wird, gut ist, dann ist der
Krieg jetzt offensichtlich
gerechtfertigt  beinhaltet Dinge wie herauszufinden,
was man einen guten Grund hat, in den Krieg zu ziehen
, aber es ist interessant, dass sie wirklich
die Idee des gerechten Krieges verteidigt, wo die
Gerechtigkeit des Krieges eher auf
Verfahrensfragen als auf dem
Ziel des Krieges oder der Art beruht  Auslöser für einen
Krieg und
es ist eine wirklich interessante Idee, weil
Sie vielleicht sogar denken, dass es
moderne Ideen vorwegnimmt, in denen wir
denken, dass Kriegsführung
legal richtig begonnen werden muss, also muss es eine
Art rechtlichen Beratungsprozess geben, durch
den die  Krieg erklärt wird, und das
würde wiederum unter Bezugnahme auf Gründe geschehen,
warum Sie in den Krieg ziehen wollen, aber die Vorstellung,
dass die Gerechtigkeit des Krieges selbst
untrennbar mit dem Prozess verbunden ist,
durch den die Entscheidung getroffen wird
, scheint etwas zu wissen
Christine, das ist wirklich interessant, okay
, das berührt nur kurz
einige der anderen Bereiche, in denen sie
interessante Dinge in der Philosophie zu sagen hat,
aber für den Rest der Zeit möchte ich mich darauf
konzentrieren  die Dinge, die sie zu unserem Thema Frauen zu sagen hat,
also ist
sie offensichtlich selbst eine Frau, sehen Sie
, das wird in
der Seife diskutiert, okay, Applaus, also die Debatte
über die Unruhen der Rose, weil ihre
Gegner sie im Grunde beschuldigen  Sie
nimmt die Haltung ein, die sie nur vertritt, weil
sie eine Frau ist, und das wird Teil
ihres Hin und Hers, wo sie
eine Romanze mit der Rose kritisiert und
andere Leute sie verteidigen, aber bevor
wir darauf eingehen, wollte ich Ihnen ein
wenig Kontext geben  Wie ich bereits sagte,
indem ich über die gesamte Tradition der
frauenfeindlichen Literatur im
Mittelalter sprach, und wie Sie sich vorstellen können, dass die
Tradition ziemlich reich ist, gibt es viel
, was wir über frauenfeindliche Literatur sagen könnten,
und es geht direkt zurück zu den
frauenfeindlichen Ideen, die wir in der
Antike fanden  und insbesondere mit der
Horizontalen. Wenn wir darüber nachdenken, was
Aristoteles gesagt hat, haben wir dort gesehen, dass
es ein paar Stränge in seiner Einstellung
gegenüber Frauen gibt
Einmal haben
wir uns seine zoologischen Schriften angesehen und
festgestellt, dass er eine Art
reduzierende Sichtweise auf die Art und Weise hat, wie das
weibliche Tier, einschließlich des weiblichen
Menschen, an der Fortpflanzung beteiligt ist
In der Generation, während das männliche Tier
Form liefert, und Sie erinnern sich vielleicht,
gab es einige Fragen darüber, wie
es dann sein könnte, dass
Kindertiere ihren Eltern ähneln, so dass das ein
Strang seines Gedankens ist und Frauen der
andere Freund mehr im politischen
Kontext kommt und hier haben wir das  Idee, dass
Frauen Männern irgendwie rational unterlegen sind,
also sagt er, dass sie vielleicht weniger
Kontrolle oder Autorität über ihre
rationalen Fähigkeiten haben als Männer und Männer,
und deshalb ist es angemessen, dass
Männer in einer Position der Herrschaft über sie sind, der
Frauen unterworfen sind  Männer mögen keine
Sklaven, sondern Assistenten und so
wäre die Idee, dass dies im Idealfall
aus Sicht von Aristoteles
offensichtlich nicht der Fall ist  meins im
idealfall hätte man den männlichen haushaltsvorstand, der
gewissermaßen die prioritäten für den gesamten
haushalt und die ganze familie festlegt, und dann hätte die
frau die tagtägliche
rolle, den haushalt zu beaufsichtigen
, das sind also ideen  die
den Mittelalter bekannt waren, einige von ihnen sind sogar
mit den zoologischen Werken von Aristoteles vertraut,
zum Beispiel Albert
der Große, der Mitte bis Ende des
Es gibt
Lektüre von Aristoteles' Politik und seiner
Ethik, die, wie wir gesehen haben, die beiden Texte sind, in
denen er über Frauen und eine Art
praktischen Kontext spricht, und so können Sie
Echos dieser aristotelischen Ideen über
Frauen in der gesamten scholastischen Literatur
des 13. und 14. Jahrhunderts finden, und das
kann ich wirklich  Zitat aus einer Reihe von Autoren in
der scholastischen Tradition, die diese Ideen wiederholten.
Ich werde nur ein Beispiel nehmen,
nicht weil er ungewöhnlich, sondern gerecht ist
weil er berühmt ist, das ist sozusagen der
Preis, den man dafür zahlt, berühmt zu sein, und
gelegentlich wird man so zitiert, und
das ist Thomas von Aquin, bevor ich anfange,
Thomas zu zitieren, möchte ich nur betonen,
dass ich ihn nicht zitiere, weil er
unter Gelehrten ungewöhnlich frauenfeindlich ist
Philosophen ist er nicht, er ist eigentlich eher
typisch, denke ich, und
deshalb zitiere ich ihn,
denn obwohl Thomas eigentlich
oft nicht der typische scholastische
Philosoph ist, hat er viele Ideen, die
seine Zeitgenossen als ziemlich
seltsam empfanden, in diesem Fall ist er so ziemlich
der  Mitte der Straße, soweit ich sehen kann
, also ist hier ein gutes Beispiel dafür, wie er
Ideen aus den zoologischen Schriften
von Aristoteles verwendete, es war notwendig, dass eine
Frau gemacht wurde, wie die Schrift sagt,
als Helferin für den Mann, nicht wirklich als Hilfe,
die in gemacht wurde  Mit anderen Worten, wie einige sagen, da einem
Mann effizienter von
einem anderen Mann geholfen werden kann, mit anderen Worten, aber da sie
ihr bei der Zeugungsarbeit helfen,
kann dies klarer gemacht werden, wenn wir o  Beachten Sie die
Art der Erzeugung, die in
verschiedenen Lebewesen bei vollkommenen
Tieren durchgeführt wird, die aktive Krafterzeugung
gehört dem männlichen Geschlecht und die passive
Kraft dem weiblichen, so dass Sie sehen können,
dass er dort genau dem dient,
was ich gerade über Aristoteles gesagt habe, nämlich
den Frauen  und tatsächlich liefern weibliche Tiere im
Allgemeinen nur das passive
Prinzip in der Generation Männer das aktive
Prinzip und offensichtlich
beeinflusst das die Art und Weise, wie Männer und Frauen
allgemeiner gesehen werden, richtig, vielleicht
klingt die Szene irgendwie metaphorisch, aber ich
denke, es ist immer noch wahr  sagen, dass sie
Frauen mit einer eher passiven Rolle assoziieren würden,
während Männer aktiv
politisch engagiert sind.
Es war interessant, dass er
diese Idee benutzte, um die Frage zu beantworten, warum
Gott Frauen überhaupt erschaffen hat, wie, was war
der Sinn davon, wenn überhaupt, ich meine den
Sinn  Selbst das Stellen der Frage
scheint die Geschlechter eher in die Irre zu führen, sodass Sie keine
Scholastiker finden, die die Frage stellen
, warum Gott, sondern warum Gott b  andere erschaffende Männer, warum
hat er nicht einfach Frauen erschaffen, was
in gewisser Weise eine sehr eigentliche Frage wäre, wäre
eine vernünftigere Frage, da Frauen
gebären und Männer es nicht mögen, wenn Gott
einen Weg hätte finden können, wie sie
gebären können, ohne zu sein  Befruchtung durch Männer
, das scheint ein
effizienterer Prozess zu sein, aber der Grund, warum er das
fragt, ist, nehme ich an, weil
Frauen offensichtlich Männern unterlegen sind,
müssen wir erklären, warum Gott sie gemacht hat,
und die Antwort ist als Hilfe für den Mann  und
beachten Sie, dass er sagt, nicht nur als Hilfe für den Mann
im Allgemeinen, denn wenn Sie Hilfe
wollen, fragen Sie einen Mann besser fast bei jeder
Gelegenheit, sondern es gibt einen bestimmten
Kontext, in dem Frauen hilfreich sind,
nämlich sie sind da, um Männern zu helfen, sich
fortzupflanzen, Sie werden das vielleicht bemerken  Das
passt nicht sehr gut zu einer anderen Idee
, die wir in dieser Serie gesehen haben, wenn es
um mittelalterliche Einstellungen gegenüber
Frauen geht, nämlich dass die ideale Frau
keusch wäre,
mit anderen Worten, sie wäre nicht sexuell
aktiv, also wie kann es simultan sein  Natürlich
hat Gott Frauen geschaffen, um Männern zu helfen, die
wir produzieren, und dass Gott idealerweise will,
dass Frauen keusch sind, und
Thomas von Aquin ist sich dieses Problems bewusst,
er erwähnt es und er hat eine Art
Unterscheidung, die es ihm ermöglicht,
das Problem zu umgehen, wo er ist  sagt, dass
sexuelle Fortpflanzung mit dem Körper zu tun hat,
während Keuschheit mit Reinheit
zu tun hat, die mit der Seele zu tun hat, und da
Frauen auch Menschen sind, ist es gut für ihre
Seelen, so tugendhaft wie möglich zu sein, und
Keuschheit als Tugend, also würde
ich das eigentlich sagen  Das ist eine bedeutende Art von
Einschränkung gegenüber dem, was wie der offenkundige
Sexismus dieser Passage erscheint, aber bevor wir Thomas von
Aquin zu schnell übertreiben,
schauen wir uns eine andere Passage an, in der er
die Frage stellte, ob Sie ihren
Vater mehr oder Ihre Mutter mehr lieben sollten, und die
Antwort stellt sich heraus  dein Vater zu sein, und
hier ist seine Erklärung dafür,
warum der Vater sicherlich mehr geliebt werden sollte
als die Mutter für den Vater und die Mutter von
als Prinzipien unseres natürlichen Ursprungs jetzt
der vater ist ein
vorbildlicher als die mutter, weil
er das aktive prinzip ist, während die
mutter ein passives und materielles prinzip ist,
folglich war der vater streng genommen
mehr zu lieben, was
wohl für sich spricht, was ich nicht
erwähnen sollte  so wie diese idee, dass
die frau passiv ist, der mann aktiv ist, hat
der mann gewissermaßen die alleinige
verantwortung für die formgebung der nachkommenschaft, die
schon in der antik und jetzt im
mittelalter nicht unumstritten war, weil
aristoteles theorie der embryologie oder
zeugungstheorie der tiere  hat wirklich
diese Idee, dass es einen einzigen Samen gibt,
dh der Forminhalt des
Kindes kommt nur aus dem Samen oder dem
Samen des Mannes des Vaters, und es
gibt konkurrierende Ansichten in der Antike, so
besonders in Galan, wo Sie einen
so haben  - genannt, um die Theorie zu sehen, mit anderen Worten, es
gibt eine Art Samen und die Frau
und es gibt auch einen Samen des Mannes,
und dann kommen sie zusammen, um
das zu produzieren  Nachkommen und deshalb
ähneln Nachkommen beiden Elternteilen, das
kommt der Wahrheit natürlich viel näher, und
diese Theorie wurde nicht nur von
Gowen, sondern auch von vielen seiner Anhänger
im Mittelalter angenommen, darunter zum Beispiel
Avicenna
in der islamischen Welt und eigentlich
Thomas 'Schülerin  Giles of Rome, den ich
bereits als Autor von
Spiegeln für Fürsten erwähnt habe, hat einen ganzen
Text über diese Frage geschrieben, ob
die Ein-Sitz-Theorie oder die TC-Theorie
zu bevorzugen ist, und er verteidigt
Aristoteles' Ein-Sitz-Theorie gegen
Kalin und einen Sohn haben als  Theorie zu sehen, also ist
dies nicht kontrovers, aber ich denke,
es ist immer noch ziemlich üblich zu sehen, dass diese
Idee der Passivität von Frauen
aus dem zoologischen oder
embryologischen Kontext von Aristoteles entlehnt und
ausgepeitscht wird, um alle möglichen
Dinge über die soziale Situation von Frauen zu erfüllen  Rolle und
Aquin spricht auch darüber, also ist hier eine
Passage, in der er sich jetzt auf
Aristoteles' Politik und Ethik stützt,
insbesondere als Politik und nicht als Politik
Zoologie, also hat er hier bestanden, er
fragt im Grunde,
was Frauen heilen müssen, und er
sagt, Unterwerfung ist zweifach, zum einen ist
Überleben oder mit anderen Worten die Art von
Unterwerfung, die in der Sklaverei auftritt,
aufgrund derer überlegen ist,
ein Subjekt zu seinem eigenen Vorteil nutzt  und diese
Art der Unterwerfung, die nach der Verurteilung begann,
ist keine Familiensklaverei, was gut ist,
es gibt eine andere Art der Unterwerfung,
die als wirtschaftliche oder zivile bezeichnet wird,
wobei der Vorgesetzte seine
Untertanen zu ihrem eigenen Nutzen und Wohl einsetzt,
und diese Art der Unterwerfung existierte schon
vorher  Sünde für die gute Ordnung
hätte in der menschlichen Familie gefehlt, wenn
einige nicht von anderen regiert würden, die weiser sind als sie
selbst,
so dass durch eine solche Art der Unterwerfung die Frau
dem Mann natürlich unterworfen ist, weil beim Mann
das Ermessen der Vernunft überwiegt,
dass die letzte Linie natürlich a ist  direktes
Zitat aus der Politik von Aristoteles,
wenn sie keine Dominanz oder
Kontrolle über ihre rationalen Fähigkeiten haben,
tun Männer und tatsächlich, was er sagt  g hier ist
wirklich interessant, ich meine, es ist ein Echo
von Aristoteles' politischer Theorie und wie
sie auf Frauen zutrifft, aber aktualisiert für die
christliche Geschichte von Adam und Eva und dem
Fall, also sagt er, dass Sie denken könnten
, dass es vorher überhaupt keine Unterwerfung gab
der Fall, also die erzwungene Sünde,
weil im ursprünglichen Naturzustand
einfach geglaubt wurde, alle wären
gleich gewesen, also gäbe es keinen Überlegenen und
Unterlegenen, es hätte keine
Sklaverei gegeben, und er sagt, richtig, es
hätte keine Sklaverei gegeben, aber es hätte
immer noch gegeben
Autoritätsbeziehungen und damit Unschuldsunterwerfung,
weil Sie das haben, was Aristoteles
politische Autorität nennt, und in einer idealen
politischen
Autoritätsbeziehung herrscht derjenige, der die Autorität hat, über
die Unterlegenen im Hinblick auf das Wohl
der Unterlegenen, also ist die Idee, dass wenn ein
Meister  hat einen Sklaven, der Meister benutzt
den Sklaven zum Nutzen des Meisters, aber
als der König über seine Untertanen war, war der
König über die Untertanen für die
b  Nutzen der Untertanen, nicht des Königs,
sonst wäre er ein Tyrann, er würde
seine Untertanen behandeln, als ob sie Sklaven wären,
und er und dann Aquinas sagen, dass diese
Art von Beziehung bereits
ohne Sünde existierte,
also sogar im Idealfall, dass
sie vor dem Fall perfekt sind  hatte eine
Beziehung von überlegen zu unterlegen, der
rationale und kontrolliertere Mann zu einer
irrational weniger kontrollierten Frau, und
das hätte bereits auf
Adam und Eva zugetroffen, deshalb war
er Adam untertan. Sie sehen eine weitere Reflexion
dieser Einstellung in einer anderen Passage, in der
er fragte  etwas, was ich
für eine ganze Serie sehr wichtig finde, daher ist die
Frage, inwieweit es Frauen
grundsätzlich erlaubt ist, ihre Idee
zu äußern, um die Fragen etwas
enger zu fassen, als dass sie
mit der Kirche sprechen dürfen, damit Sie dies möglicherweise nicht tun
Vergleichen Sie dies sogar mit der Frage
heutzutage, ob Frauen
Priester werden dürfen, aber die Frage ist nicht
ganz so technisch, die Frage ist
wirklich, sollte das C  Die christliche Gemeinschaft
hört den Stimmen von Frauen in einem
öffentlichen Kontext zu und seine Antwort ist
deprimierend, aber nicht überraschend, nein,
sie sollten Frauen dies nicht
erlauben, sie
sollten grundsätzlich nur privat sprechen dürfen, also
hat er Folgendes zu sagen  Diese
Fragerede kann auf zweierlei Weise verwendet werden,
einmal privat zu einem oder mehreren in
vertrauten Gesprächen, und in dieser
Hinsicht kann die Gnade des Wortes
Frauen zugute kommen, sodass sie
grundsätzlich religiös unter
ihren Freunden und Familienmitgliedern missionieren dürfen  eine andere Weise,
sich öffentlich an die ganze
Kirche zu wenden, und dies ist den
Frauen zunächst und hauptsächlich wegen
der an das weibliche
Geschlecht geknüpften Bedingung nicht gestattet, wonach die Frau dem Mann untertan sein soll,
wie es aus der Genesis hervorgeht, jetzt
öffentlich in der Kirche zu lehren und zu überzeugen,
gehört nicht dazu  den Untertanen, sondern den
Prälaten, obwohl Männer, die Untertanen
sind, diese Dinge tun können, wenn sie dazu
berechtigt sind, weil ihre Unterwerfung
nein ist  Ein Ergebnis ihres natürlichen Geschlechts, weil
es Frauen sind, die etwas Super
treffen, zweitens, weniger männliche
Gemüter zur Lust verleitet werden, so dass Sie nicht
wollen, dass Frauen öffentlich mit Männern sprechen,
weil es ihnen sexuelle Ideen geben könnte,
drittens, weil in der Regel Frauen
nicht vollkommen in der Weisheit sind
, um mit öffentlichem Unterricht betraut zu werden,
und dass wiederum der letzte Satz
als Anspielung auf diese Idee bei Aristoteles
genau dort nicht perfekt in der Weisheit sein könnte, so
dass dies sicherlich mit dieser
Idee zusammenhängt, dass sie rational sind  Fakultäten
sind nicht unter Kontrolle, es gibt weniger
als Männer. Ich versuche nicht zu sagen,
dass Aquin ungewöhnlich sexistisch war, wenn es um
scholastische Philosophen geht, und
ich versuche nicht einmal zu sagen, dass dies
ein Thema ist, das Thomas besonders betrifft
mich interessiert, also habe ich diese Passagen
herausgesucht, weil sie sehr auffallend sind,
aber sie stammen alle von dieser Nachahmung, oh
ja, es ist die berühmteste und wichtigste Arbeit,
aber diese Frau ist riesig, und ich habe sie
dir besorgt  Ich kenne
aus dieser
massiven Arbeit eine Art Textbrocken in Absatzgröße, aber es ist nicht so, dass Sie
lange Diskussionen über Frauen geführt haben. Es kommt
immer vor, dass Frauen auftauchen, wenn Sie
über ein anderes Thema sprechen, und
dann sagt er so nebenbei, oh,
hier ist das  Kleines Problem,
das über Frauen auftaucht und auftaucht Ich werde das ansprechen und
weitermachen und das ist ziemlich üblich Ich bin
typisch für die scholastische Philosophie, sie
interessieren sich wirklich nicht sehr für Frauen
als Thema und sie machen Bemerkungen
über Frauen eher beiläufig  wenn
sie frauenfeindlich sind, sind sie beiläufig
frauenfeindlich und sie sind es nicht, sie haben nicht
wirklich die Idee von Frauenfeindlichkeit als
Projekt, es ist kein großer Teil der
scholastischen Literatur, einfach weil
Frauen kein Thema in der scholastischen
Literatur sind  ganz
im vordergrund eigentlich habe ich einen artikel darüber gelesen,
in dem die autorin durch viele,
viele passagen und scholastik als
erwähnte frauen ging und sie zu dem schluss kam, dass
im allgemeinen frauen wirklich
In der scholastischen Literatur treten sie fast nie als
Thema von primärem Interesse auf, sie
tauchen fast immer auf, wenn
Menschen Gedankenexperimente
oder Beispiele in Betracht ziehen, um einen breiteren Punkt zu veranschaulichen.
Mein Lieblingsbeispiel dafür ist,
dass der
Gantz-Ruff-Zeitgenosse von Aquin 'als
Wunder was  sollte passieren, wenn der
Ehemann von jemandem stirbt und die Frau wieder
heiratet, aber dann die Frau, der
erste Ehemann der Frau, die gestorben ist, aufersteht, also ist
ihr erster Ehemann jetzt wieder am Leben
und sie hat rechtmäßig einen
zweiten Mann geheiratet und die Frage ist, ob
sie gehen soll  zurück zu ihrem ersten Ehemann oder nicht
okay, das heißt also nicht, dass es
im Mittelalter überhaupt kein Genre des frauenfeindlichen Schreibens
gibt, tatsächlich gibt es definitiv
keine scholastische Philosophie, also hat es
wirklich mehr zu Hause und das
könnte ein bisschen sein  überraschend, aber da es
in der Literatur und Poesie zu Hause ist und
oft an den Rändern des
Genres liegt, das wir uns ziemlich oft angesehen haben
Das ist höfische Liebeslyrik,
also könnte man hier an Figuren wie
Methode von Magdeburg und Haida-
Hündin zurückdenken, die sich auf die Tropen und Themen der
höfischen Liebe stützten, insbesondere auf diese Idee, dass
der Liebende
für den Geliebten so in ihren Schriften das
Leiden verschmachtet und leidet  Liebhaber ist die weibliche Mystikerin, der
Geliebte ist Gott oder Christus, und die
Betonung liegt wirklich auf dem Leiden,
und schon hier könnte man erkennen,
dass, wenn man die
Implikationen davon durchdenkt, da
der Liebhaber im höfischen Liebeskontext keine
weibliche Mystikerin ist, sondern  Ein Mann, der
sich in gewisser Weise nach einer unerreichbaren Frau sehnt, lautet
die Botschaft der höfischen Liebeslyrik,
dass Frauen diese reinen, unberührbaren
Objekte sind, die Männern Leiden zufügen,
nur indem sie existieren, also nur indem sie sie provozieren
und lieben, vielleicht weiß die Frau das
vielleicht nicht einmal  das gibt
es gibt es viele oft gibt es unsere art
von trope und höfischer liebespoesie, dass
der mann leidenschaftlich in
diese frau verliebt ist, nur um zu sehen  In ihr, ohne dass
es sie getroffen oder mit ihr gesprochen hat,
so dass die Frau es nicht unbedingt
weiß,
sie hat es nicht absichtlich provoziert,
nur weil sie schön ist, indem sie weiblich ist
, hat sie dieses Leiden provoziert, aber
Frauen sind trotzdem so
Quelle unendlichen erbärmlichen Leidens bei
Männern und sehe dies sogar in einer Art
Gründungstext der höfischen Liebesliteratur
in der Definition der Liebe, die es gibt,
also überlasse ich dies dir, also ist dies
von Alices Werk über die Liebe und das entkleidete Paar Alice
und er definiert  Liebe als ein gewisses angeborenes
Leiden, das dadurch verursacht wird, dass man
zu viel über die Pracht einer
Person des anderen Geschlechts sieht und darüber nachdenkt, so dass
man sieht, wie tief die Idee des
Leidens mit der
Idee der Liebe zwischen einem Mann und einer Frau verbunden ist
und  Vielleicht hilft es uns auch zu
verstehen, warum Figuren wie Wasserstoffhälse,
was wir in der Lage sind, diese zu übernehmen
und die Ideen der höfischen Liebeslyrik
und die Sprache der höfischen Liebeslyrik
zu verwenden, um die Mysti zu beschreiben  cs Leiden und
Schmachten nach Gott, das ist an
sich schon schlimm genug, aber
es ist nicht so wie unverschämt, dass es
explizit frauenfeindlich ist, aber tatsächlich
gibt es eine ziemlich lange Tradition
frauenfeindlichen Schreibens im Mittelalter, und
vielleicht ist das beste Beispiel dafür a  sehr
selbstbewusst, was in
William Chaucer, dem Autor von The Canterbury
Tales, vorkommt, also gibt es es jetzt gegen
Ende des 14. Jahrhunderts,
also ist er ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit wie zum
Beispiel Julian von Norwich und
schreibt auch in Mittelenglisch, aus der
er auch ungefähr stammt  Das frühe
Leben von Christine de Pizan sagt, er
stirbt Ende
des 14. Jahrhunderts, als sie noch eine
junge Frau ist, und eine der
faszinierendsten Reflexionen über mittelalterliche
Frauenfeindlichkeit kommt tatsächlich in The
Canterbury Tales in der Geschichte der
Frau von Bath so wie Sie  Wahrscheinlich wissen Sie, dass die
Canterbury Tales ein Gedicht sind, in dem eine
Gruppe von Pilgern zusammen reist
und sie einen Wettbewerb veranstalten, also wird der
Wettbewerb von demjenigen gewonnen, der w  Wer
kann die beste Geschichte erzählen, und es gibt eine
Art allgemeinen Prolog,
der die Charaktere vorstellt, und dann bekommt
jeder der Charaktere, die eine Geschichte erzählen, einen
eigenen Prolog, in dem sie
näher beschrieben werden, und dann machen sie
vielleicht einige Bemerkungen, die ihre
Geschichte einleiten und  dann erzählen sie ihre Geschichte, und
eine der Figuren, die
hier wichtig ist, ist die Frau von Bath, sie ist
eine faszinierende Figur, die endlich sogar
ihren eigenen Teil in dieser Vortragsreihe verdient hat,
sie ist unglaublich nett,
sie ist lustig, sie ist schlau, sie ist
zynisch, sie spricht darüber  Reihe von
Ehemännern, die sie hatte, und wie
sehr sie unter den
meisten ihrer Ehemänner gelitten hat, also könnte man meinen, dass
Chaucer
ihr gegenüber sehr sympathisch ist und auf eine Weise
, die richtig erscheint, aber er scheint sie auch
hereinzulegen  als Objekt der Lächerlichkeit,
weil er ihr erlaubt,
über ihre eigenen sexuellen Wünsche und ihr eigenes
schlechtes Benehmen zu sprechen, also ist es wirklich sehr schwer,
actua zu lesen  lly und Gelehrte streiten
darüber viel darüber, was
wir von der Frau von Bath halten sollen, wir sollen
sie missbilligen und sie ist
lächerlich, sollen wir
mit ihr sympathisieren oder was, und all diese Fragen
kommen irgendwie zu einem  Gehen Sie zum
Ende ihres Prologs, wenn sie beschreibt, dass sie
mit diesem einen aus der Reihe von
Ehemännern verheiratet war, dass sie einen Angestellten hatte, mit anderen
Worten, eine Art Gelehrter oder jemand,
der in der wissenschaftlichen Welt in Oxford studiert hat,
und dieser Hof hieß Jenkin und  er
hat die unglückliche Angewohnheit,
ihr jede Nacht aus Texten vorzulesen, die sie
das Buch der bösen Frauen nennt, das im
Grunde eine
Zusammenstellung mittelalterlicher Texte und alter Texte ist
, die schlechte Dinge über Frauen zu sagen haben,
und Chaucer sagt uns tatsächlich, welche
Autoren die Quellen sind  Für Jenkins
frauenfeindliche Sammlung ist überraschenderweise
eine der erwähnten Autorinnen Heloise,
die Schülerin und Liebhaberin von Abaelard, und Sie
könnten denken, warum sollte warum eine
frauenfeindliche Sammlung  so möchte
ich Heloise zitieren. Die Antwort ist, weil
Heloise dieses leidenschaftliche Argument geschrieben hat
, um ein großes Argument zu haben, dass er
sie nicht heiraten sollte, und daher ihre Argumente
gegen die Ehe oder als Teil
dieses allgemeinen Angriffs auf Frauen und damit,
mit Frauen verheiratet zu sein, verwendet werden  Was passiert, ist, dass
die Frau von Bath es schließlich nicht mehr ertragen kann,
dass sie sich
all diese Frauenfeindlichkeit anhören muss, also nimmt sie
Jenkin das Buch weg, diese Freude ist
es, und er schlägt sie so brutal, dass
sie taub wird und ich  Ich
wollte Ihnen nur aus der kleinen kleinen Passage vorlesen,
in der die Canterbury Tales
tatsächlich waren, tatsächlich war die Frau
davon und die Canterbury Tales beschreiben
das Buch, das er ihr vorlas, und
ich werde es einfach sozusagen in
modernes Englisch übersetzen, während ich gehe  und jede Nacht und jeden
Tag, wenn er
Muße und Urlaub von jenseitigen
Beschäftigungen hatte, war es seine Gewohnheit, aus diesem Buch von bösen Ehefrauen zu lesen, für die
er keine Legenden und
Ehefrauen über gute Ehefrauen in der Bibel kannte
Sie können glauben, dass es unmöglich ist, dass
irgendein Angestellter, ein Nerd und sein Gelehrter
, gut über Funk sprechen wird, sei es über das Leben der
heiligsten Heiligen oder überhaupt über andere
Frauen
Frau
zeigen, dass sie sich ihrer Art von zwangloser Frauenfeindlichkeit der Gelehrtenwelt bewusst ist, über
die wir gerade mit Thomas von
Aquin und anderen Scholastikern gesprochen haben, also ist dies
ein wirklich
interessantes und faszinierendes Beispiel für
die Existenz frauenfeindlicher Literatur
in der mittelalterlichen Kultur, natürlich dieses Buch
der Bösen  Ehefrauen wie die Ehefrau von
Bath selbst existieren nicht als
fiktiver Text, den Chaucer erfunden hat,
aber die Idee ist, dass der fiktive
Text auf dieser langen Tradition von
Schriften gegen Frauen beruht, und
tatsächlich gibt es tatsächlich eine Art Debatte, die
es gegeben hat  weitergehen und dann dort später seit
mindestens dem 12. Jahrhundert mit literarischen
Figuren, die Gedichte schreiben, die Frauen angreifen,
sogar die gleichen literarischen fi  Wenn Sie vielleicht
sowohl Frauen loben als auch
gegen Frauen schreiben, als eine Art
rhetorische Eloquenz, und Sie
Argumente hin und her haben, erinnern Sie sich vielleicht
, dass Abaelard sich zur
Verteidigung von Frauen erhoben und diese
leidenschaftliche Abhandlung geschrieben hat, in der er argumentiert,
dass Frauen oft sind  tugendhaft und diese
Verteidigungen von Frauen machen oft die gleichen
Punkte, genau wie die frauenfeindliche
Literatur die gleichen Punkte macht, also wird die
frauenfeindliche Literatur
Frauen normalerweise beschuldigen, Klatsch zu sein,
neidisch zu sein, von materiellem Reichtum besessen zu sein
und sexuell unersättlich zu sein, sie
schlafen herum, was sie getan hat  ihre
Ehemänner sie treiben ihre Ehemänner zur
Verzweiflung Auch mit einer Frau verheiratet zu sein
ist schrecklich für dein Leben als
Gelehrter und Philosoph, weil
du in diesen familiären Kontext hineingezogen wirst,
wo du keine Zeit und Ruhe hast und du dich
vielleicht daran erinnerst, dass dies einer der
Gründe, warum diese argumentieren, dass
Abaelard sie nicht heiraten sollte, weil
es schlecht für einen Philosophen ist, verheiratet zu sein,
preve  hält sie davon ab, Philosophie zu betreiben, also
sind dies die Themen, mit denen Sie immer
wieder konfrontiert werden  dagegen argumentieren, dass
alle Frauen sündig und sexuell
besessen sind, sie bringen Fälle von
weiblicher Askese vor, um gegen die Vorstellung zu argumentieren
, dass Frauen von Reichtum
und materiellem Besitz besessen sind. Sie sehen
dies oft in einer Art theologischen Kontext,
in dem die Frauenfeinde immer
die Rolle betonten  von Eva, die Adam zur
Sünde und dem Garten Eden verleitete, und die Anti-
Frauenfeindlichkeit wie Abaelard kommen zurück und
sagen: „Gut, aber was ist mit der Jungfrau Maria
?“ Sie können also nicht sagen, dass alle Frauen
einfach sind, weil wir wissen, dass die Jungfrau
Maria ohne Sünde ist  und tatsächlich sehen
sie Maria als Erlösung des gesamten
weiblichen Geschlechts von Evas Erbsünde an,
fast so wie Christus
das Ich der Menschheit erlöst  Auf kleinere Weise
erlöst Marys Fehlerlosigkeit die Weiblichkeit
in gewissem Sinne, also führt diese Debatte
hin und her, und dies wird
wirklich den intensiven Streit
auslösen, der um 1400 über ein
bestimmtes Werk, die Romanze der Rose, aufkommt,
also jetzt wir  Wir geraten in die sogenannte
Debatte über die Romanze der Rose oder
neigen dazu, es ist auf Französisch die Debatte über
die Rose, also wurde die Romanze der Rose
selbst in gewissem Sinne ziemlich viel früher geschrieben,
übrigens, das ist dies
eine  Deshalb halte ich es für sinnvoll,
über all dies
immer noch als mittelalterliches Thema zu sprechen, auch wenn
wir Christine de Pizan in
gewissem Sinne als Renaissancefigur betrachten, ist die
Romanze von Rose eindeutig ein mittelalterlicher
Text, also wurde sie im 13.
Jahrhundert geschrieben  Es hat eigentlich zwei Teile, der
erste Teil, der viel kürzer ist,
wurde im frühen 13. Jahrhundert geschrieben und ist
ein ziemlich typisches Werk höfischer Liebe, da
es diese Art von symbolischem Rahmen ist,
in dem der Autor davon erzählt,
wie er es hatte  einschläft und einen Traum hat,
in dem er ein Liebhaber ist, der sich
nach dieser Rose sehnt, die Rose
symbolisiert offensichtlich eine begehrenswerte Frau, und das
Gedicht war unvollendet und wurde
gegen Ende des dreizehnten
Jahrhunderts von einem anderen Drittel namens Jean de Mirin und aufgenommen und vervollständigt  Shondor
Birns Abschluss ist viel länger als der
erste Teil, also beendet er ihn, aber
indem er ihn beendet, macht er es mehr als
dreimal so lang, und wie ich schon sagte,
was in dem Gedicht passiert, ist, dass die Liebhaberfigur
manchmal den träumenden Dichter darstellt  Ich dachte an
den törichten Liebhaber, der irgendwie
durch diesen Garten wandert und all diese Charaktere trifft,
wie ich zuvor sagte, so wie
Neid oder Eifersucht oder eine Freundin oder alte
Frau oder Klatsch, und das sind
übrigens alle Charaktere, einschließlich
des Glücksgottes  selbst, die irgendwie
in romantische Beziehungen verwickelt sind, und sie geben
ihm verschiedene Ratschläge und verschiedene
Perspektiven auf Romantik und dann ganz am
Ende er zusammen mit dem fo
Der Liebesgott stürmt das Schloss, in dem
die Rose verteidigt wird, bricht sich ein
und dann gibt es eine Passage, in der er, ich
denke, man kann nur das Wort D verwenden,
die Rose blüht, und es wird genau so beschrieben,
ich meine, es ist nicht  ganz
subtil ist es voller Doppeldeutigkeit,
also beschreibt es den Zugang zu dieser Rose auf eine
Weise, die sehr offensichtlich
den Geschlechtsverkehr symbolisieren soll, so
dass es in gewisser
Weise ein sehr vulgärer Text ist, und es
gibt noch andere  Passagen früher in der
Arbeit, die auch für mittelalterliche Verhältnisse eine
ziemlich explizite Terminologie für die
Geschlechtsorgane verwenden, und dies ist ein Grund, warum
Autoren wie Christine the Design
sich über die Romantik von Rosen beschwerten,
sagten sie im Grunde, dass dies funktionierte, was
viele Menschen in Frankreich für ihn halten  Ein
großartiges literarisches Werk in französischer
Sprache, es mag in seiner Sprache schön sein
, es mag eloquent sein, aber es ist
auch ziemlich krass, also ist das ein Teil
des Einwands, aber der grundlegendere
Einwand  n ist, dass das Gedicht voll von
diesen frauenfeindlichen Passagen ist,
offensichtlich nie in John de Moons eigener
Stimme, sondern immer in die Stimmen
dieser Personifikationen hineinversetzt, und insbesondere
gibt es eine Szene, in der der Liebhaber
mit der Figur des Freundes spricht und
den Freund beschreibt  Die Notlage des
sogenannten eifersüchtigen Ehemanns, der
von seiner Frau misshandelt wird, sagt weiter,
dass der eifersüchtige Ehemann am Ende
seine Frau schlagen wird, genau wie in
der Geschichte von Jenkin und der Frau von Bath, und außerdem
haben wir jetzt eine Jean de Moon, die
über einen Freund schreibt  Er spricht darüber, was der
eifersüchtige Ehemann von seiner Frau und
von Frauen im Allgemeinen hält, also
spricht er zum einen über Frauen als eine Art
bösartige Charaktere, und er sagt, dass kein
Mann, der eine Frau hat, sicher ist, so
sorgfältig er sie bewacht und
beobachtet  wenn er tausend Augen hat, lassen sich alle Weiber
flachlegen, denn kein Wärter kann
etwas dagegen tun, und sollte es doch einmal
vorkommen, dass die Tat gewollt ist, wird der
Wille dazu nie fehlen  Mit anderen
Worten, auch wenn sie keine Chance hat,
zu betrügen, wird sie es immer tun wollen,
aber wenn sie kann, wird sie
die Chance nutzen, um es immer zu tun
, aber das Geschäft, das wir Wetten nennen, ist
das Geringste  der Sünden, die die
Kunst der Frauen beflecken, denn ihre Natur veranlasst
jede von ihnen, sich darauf zu konzentrieren, es
euch allen schlechter zu machen, mit anderen Worten,
alles, was ihr Frauen seid, wird tatsächlich sein und gewesen sein,
oder eine Aufmerksamkeit, die unkeusch ist, oder ihr
könnt das ansprechen  hat Poren, denn selbst
wenn die Tat verhindert werden kann,
kann kein Mann den Willen zügeln, alle Frauen
haben den Vorteil, Herrin
ihrer eigenen zu
sein  Idee,
dass Frauen immer sündig sind, sie betrügen
dich, sie sind bösartig und anders als
die anderen, die geplant sind, ist, dass die Ehe
nur schlecht für Männer ist, also sahen wir unter Scott
Lanas Spruch, dass Liebe immer eine
Frage des Leidens ist, wir sahen sogar, wie es
uns geht  Die Behauptung, dass die Ehe die
Aussichten auf wissenschaftliche Exzellenz behindert,
da dr.  Phil, der Philosoph
und der eifersüchtige Ehemann ist,
beklagt natürlich die Tatsache, dass er jemals
geheiratet hat, also sagt er, dass die Ehe ein böses
Band ist, es wäre besser für mich gewesen,
an dem Tag gehängt zu werden, an dem ich heirate, und
mich an eine so elegante Frau zu binden und  der
grund, warum er sich über die eleganz beschwert,
ist, dass es so viel geld gekostet habe,
die frau zu halten und man könne kleider
und gute kleider in ordnung bringen, also antworten
christine de pizan und andere kritiker
der rosenromantik um 1400
so sogar  Bevor wir darauf eingehen
, möchte ich nur darauf hinweisen, dass
Christine de Pizan, obwohl sie
offensichtlich eine sehr nachdrückliche Verteidigerin
der Tugend der Frau ist, nicht jemand ist
, der behaupten will, dass Frauen
irgendwie völlig gleichberechtigt mit Männern sind, also
könnte man meinen  Dies ist eine
rhetorische Strategie, und tatsächlich eine
rhetorische Strategie, die wir
im Mittelalter schon viele Male gesehen haben, aber
sie achtet darauf, ihren Angriff auf die
Romantik der Rose zu umrahmen, indem sie gut klo sagt  k
Ich bin kein ausgebildeter Gelehrter Vortrag auf dem
Mond war also ich nicht Ich schreibe keine
beredten lateinischen und französischen Verse eigentlich
ist sie natürlich sehr beredt, aber
sie sagt irgendwie mit falscher Demut
, dass sie es nicht ist und ich  Ich bin nur eine
Frau, aber ich denke
trotzdem, wir werden gleich darauf zurückkommen,
aber sie sagt solche Dinge nicht nur
, sondern in einem anderen Kontext,
in dem sie nicht über die
Romanze der Reihen oder Frauenfeindlichkeit sprach
Dass auch sie teilweise
etwas traditionelle Vorstellungen von der
Rolle der Frau in einer Familie hat, sehen wir nur daran, dass
sie einen Ratschlag an einen
ihrer Söhne geschrieben hat, in dem sie folgendes
über seine Beziehungen zu der
zukünftigen Ehefrau sagt  Haben Sie eine gute und
weise Frau, glauben Sie ihr über den Zustand
des Haushalts und vertrauen Sie auf ein Wort, aber sprechen Sie
nicht vertraulich mit einer dummen,
also meine ich, sie wiederholt
die dumme Frau, der man keine Geheimnisse anvertrauen kann,
natürlich auch sie  denkt
, dass es möglich ist, eine gute zu haben  und
tugendhafte Ehefrau, aber selbst die gute
tugendhafte Ehefrau bemerkt nicht
, dass sie diejenige sein wird, die den
Haushalt führt, also ist sie ich meine, das ist kaum
überraschend, aber sie ist nicht wie eine
Feministin der 1970er Jahre, die sagt, dass
wir mit
stereotypen Ideen vollständig aufräumen sollten  über die Rolle von
Frauen im Haushalt so, dass sie das
erkennt und nicht in Frage stellt,
dass es eine Art Vorurteil über
die Rolle von Frauen und Männern und das Familienleben
gibt und dass diese Rollen dennoch unterschiedlich sind
, sicherlich je nach dem Prozentsatz
ihres Tages, an dem sie lebt  sehr energische
Verfechterin der Tugend und Ehre der Frauen und wir
sehen dies in ihrem Angriff auf die Romantik
der Rose, also ist hier eine Passage aus ihrem
Angriff ihr Einstieg in die Debatte, also erklärt sie hier
, dass ihr Angriff auf die
Romantik der Rose nicht rein ist  weil
sie weiblich ist und dass sie versucht,
die Tugend der Frauen nur auf dieser Grundlage zu rechtfertigen,
glauben Sie nicht, mein Herr, und kein
anderer Mensch darf diese Meinung haben, die ich
habe  die vorgenannten Rechtfertigungen angegeben oder aufgezählt habe
oder dass
sie auf voreingenommenen Ausreden beruhen,
weil ich eine Frau bin, denn in Bezug auf meine
Motivation und die ursprüngliche
Motivation, die Romantik der Rose anzugreifen,
ergibt sich nichts anderes, als einfach
die reine Wahrheit zu vertreten, da durch bewiesenes
Wissen  Ich weiß, dass diese Wahrheit
den Behauptungen widerspricht, die ich
widerlegt habe, aber da ich tatsächlich eine
Frau bin, bin ich besser geeignet, diese Dinge zu bezeugen, als jemand, der
diese Erfahrung nicht gemacht hat,
sie ausspricht und mit
Vermutungen und aufs Geratewohl festlegt  Ich
denke, das ist eine wirklich faszinierende
Passage, denn was sie dort sagt, ist
, wenn wir darüber reden, ob
Frauen immer sündig und böse sind,
warum dann nicht meiner Ansicht nach ernst nehmen, dass ich eine
Frau bin, also sollte ich es wissen,
und während Ajanta es war  ein Mann würde er
nicht weniger gut als ich und das
ist tatsächlich eine sehr ungewöhnliche Sache, wenn man
darüber nachdenkt, also haben wir verschiedene
Strategien gesehen, die während des gesamten Mittelalters
verwendet wurden  r Frauen das Recht zu beanspruchen,
öffentlich zu sprechen, was Razak-Wein
ihnen zumindest in einem kirchlichen Kontext verweigert,
zum Beispiel haben wir gesehen
, wie sie Dinge sagten wie „Ich bin nur ein
demütiges Gefäß, aber für die Stimme Gottes
und seit Gottes Frieden durch  mir
sollten Sie zuhören, was ich zu sagen habe, aber
hier sagt Christine eigentlich,
gerade weil sie eine Frau ist
, sollte ihre Stimme ernst genommen werden,
weil sie in gewissem Sinne eine Expertin für
das vorliegende Thema ist, weil das Thema
Frauen ist, okay, also jetzt offensichtlich was  Sie
wird diese fachkundige
Autoritätsposition nutzen, um den
frauenfeindlichen Angriff von Shondor Birns auf
Frauen zu erklären oder zumindest den frauenfeindlichen
Angriff auf Frauen, den wir in der
Romanze der Rose finden, ob das nun Jean
Demoon spricht oder nicht, wie Sie sehen
werden  Ein weiteres Thema, das in
der Debatte auftaucht, aber was sie tun möchte, ist
, Jean de Moon dafür anzugreifen, dass er diese frauenfeindlichen
Passagen in sein Gedicht
eingefügt hat, und etwas Interessantes daran
ist, dass es nicht an ist  Leugnet sie nicht die
Art von Eloquenz und Schönheit und
literarische Qualität des Gedichts, die
Romantik der Rose, gibt sie es nicht zu und
sagt, das mache es noch schlimmer,
weil Jean de Muniz es besser wissen müsste,
da er so ein kluger Kerl ist und  Auch
die Tatsache, dass die
Frauenfeindlichkeit so eloquent und effektiv
im Kontext eines wunderbar
schönen Literaturwerks präsentiert wird, macht es noch
schädlicher, weil Sie eher
an die frauenfeindliche Botschaft glauben, die es
vermittelt. Hier ist, was sie dazu sagt
Mein Urteil gibt zu, dass Meister Jean
Demun ein sehr großartiger, subtiler und eloquenter Angestellter ist,
und er hätte
eine viel bessere Arbeit produzieren können, profitabler und
mit einer höheren Sensibilität, wenn
er sich ihnen gewidmet hätte,
also ist es schade, dass er es nicht getan hat  Ich
nehme an, dass ihn vielleicht die große
Geilheit, von der er erfüllt war
, eher in Richtung
seines Verlangens als in Richtung der Produktion
von etwas Nützlichem und Nützlichem bewegte  Obwohl
es häufig vorkommt, dass die
Neigungen von Menschen durch ihre Handlungen bekannt werden,
billige ich sicherlich
nicht alle Teile des Raums
zur Rose 4. Es gibt
zweifellos einige gute Dinge, die
Lee erfreut, aber umso größer zum Ausdruck bringt
Je authentischer das
Gute ist, desto mehr Glaubwürdigkeit wird
dem Bösen zugesprochen. Der Grund, warum
es eine Debatte gibt, liegt darin, dass einige andere
Aristokraten und das sind alle,
die an dieser Debatte beteiligt sind, im Grunde
irgendwie an dem Tsunami hängen  am
französischen Hof, so dass wir
über sehr gut ausgebildete reiche
Aristokraten sprachen, die an dieser
Debatte beteiligt sind, und viele von ihnen lieben die
Romantik der Rosen wirklich, sie hielten es für
eines der größten Werke der
französischen Literatur, die es gab  Bis zu
diesem Zeitpunkt haben sie sich also zu seiner Verteidigung erhoben,
und natürlich haben sie sich zu seiner Verteidigung
in einer Weise erhoben, dass ich meine, sie haben nicht nur
die Frauenfeindlichkeit als solche verteidigt,
wie wir noch sehen werden  Sie versuchen, das
Zeigen des Mondes von dem Vorwurf freizusprechen,
frauenfeindlich zu sein, aber die Art und Weise, wie sie auf Christine reagieren,
ist selbst frauenfeindlich, wie Sie
vielleicht erwarten würden
Romanze der Rose
Dies ist, indem ich zu einer Erkältung gehe,
die sagt, ich bin sehr treu, Zuneigung
aufgrund Ihrer Tugenden und Verdienste und
aufgrund dieser ermahnten Ratschläge und
Bitten Sie zunächst in einem Brief, den ich
Ihnen vorgestern schickte, zu
korrigieren und  ihre Haltung in
Bezug auf diesen offensichtlichen Fehler, Torheit oder
Sinnlosigkeit, die zu Ihnen kam, als
Ergebnis von Anmaßung und Arroganz, dass
Sie eine Frau sind, die sich leidenschaftlich auf diese Weise engagiert,
wiedergutmachen, also sagt er offensichtlich irgendwie herablassend gut den Grund,
warum Sie sich darüber so aufregen  Romance of
Roses, dass du eine Frau bist und es
dich sehr emotional macht, das ist im Grunde sein
Vorschlag. Ich meine, die Oberfläche, was er da
gesagt hat, war ziemlich höflich, aber
sie ist al  Angesichts der herablassenden
Haltung, die er einnimmt, schreibt sie
gleich zurück und sagt, wenn Sie meine
Argumente wegen
der Dürftigkeit meiner Fähigkeiten, für die
Sie mich ansprechen, so weit abwerten, wenn Sie sagen, dass Sie eine
Frau sind, sollten Sie wissen, dass ich nicht darin bin
Betrachten Sie dies in Wahrheit überhaupt als unseren Ansatz
zur Verleumdung, denn der Trost, der
sich aus der edlen Erinnerung und
fortgesetzten Erfahrung einer großen
Fülle edler Frauen ergibt, die
höchst lobenswert und
an jede tugendhafte Tätigkeit gewöhnt waren und sind,
würde ich ihnen eher ähneln als
leider von allen Führern reich gemacht werden,
so dass der Punkt, den sie dort macht,
gut aussieht, wenn Sie im Grunde das
ignorieren, was ich zu sagen habe, weil
ich eine Frau bin und wir wissen, dass Frauen
irrational und sündig sind, denken Sie noch einmal nach,
weil ich ziemlich bin  glücklich, zu
den Frauen gezählt zu werden, weil so viele
Frauen tugendhaft waren, und er oder sie
rechnet mit einem Argument, das sie
in einem späteren Text viel ausführlicher führen wird
Ein viel längerer Test namens City
of Ladies, also ist die Idee hier, dass
Christine sich so groß darstellt, dass
es ein weiterer dieser Texte ist, in dem
die Autorin als Hauptfigur auftritt,
genau wie in der Romanze der Rose
selbst oder in Dantes Göttlicher Komödie und
Sie beschreibt sich selbst, wie sie einen
frauenfeindlichen Text liest und in Verzweiflung gerät,
weil sie überzeugt ist, dass ihr
Geschlecht sündhaft, schwach, irrational und
so weiter ist, und dann wird sie von drei
Frauen besucht, was wieder etwas hervorruft, das wir immer wieder
gesehen haben, nämlich dass weibliche
Charaktere auftauchen  als eine Art
Personifikation von Philosophie oder
Gerechtigkeit oder Wahrheit oder was auch immer, und
so tauchen diese drei Personifikationen hier
auf und sagen, was ist los
mit dir, wie kannst du dich gegen dein
eigenes Geschlecht wenden, merkst du nicht, dass
es so viele Beispiele gibt  von großen Frauen in der
Geschichte, die uns zeigen, dass Frauen
keusch sein können, sie können tugendhaft sein, sie können
sogar Gelehrte sein, sie können gute Herrscher sein,
und sie machen t  Seine lange Geschichte
guter Frauen und der Ideen
Die Art zentrale Metapher des Textes
ist, dass sie eine Stadt für Frauen bauen,
in der die Fundamente und Mauern die
Geschichten über diese guten Frauen sind,
die bereits in heidnischen Zeiten gelebt haben, damit
Frauen nicht alle sind  Christen, aber sie
erwähnt auch offensichtlich christliche Frauen,
Frauen im Alten Testament, die Jungfrau
Maria und so weiter. Eines der Dinge, die
sie hier so interessant macht, ist, dass
sie nicht nur sagt, was wir
vielleicht von Leuten wie
Julian von Norwich erwartet hätten  oder Katharina von Siena,
sie sagt nicht nur, oh, man kann nicht behaupten,
dass Frauen immer sündig sind
und von sexuellem Verlangen verzehrt werden, weil man nur
an all die gejagten Frauenheiligen denkt
, die nicht verheiratet waren, und so
weiter, sie erwähnt Charaktere
so natürlich, aber sie erhebt auch die Verteidigung
des Ehelebens und der Frau in der Ehe,
und ich möchte Sie eigentlich
von einem Artikel über die Stadt der Frauen
führen, der von zwei s geschrieben wurde  Die Gelehrten Glenda
McLeod und Katharina Wilson Sie sagen in
der Stadt der Damen die Argumente der
philosophischen Asad-Gunness, also nicht
frauenfeindlich, sondern sahen eine Waffenmythen, mit anderen
Worten Leute, die gegen die Ehe schreiben,
dass Frauen ihre Ehemänner nicht lieben,
dass sie nicht in der Lage sind, das zu
lieben  sie sind eine Belastung für die
Zeit und die Ressourcen eines Philosophen, also sind dies die
Themen, die wir sogar in Heloise gesehen haben. Diese
Argumente werden von
ihren Beispielen liebevoller Frauen
angegriffen, wenn sie die Gelehrten Sin Pipi und Pompeji Paulina lieben,
wenn sie Sokrates in Seneca
Christines einzigem Overt gegenüber stehen  Vorschlag für
gesellschaftlichen Wandel Die Bildung von Frauen
wird bald darauf eingeführt Eine direkte
Herausforderung für das Argument, dass
Frauen nicht den geistigen Scharfsinn haben, um ein
Studium oder fleißige Ehemänner zu schätzen, ist ziemlich
logisch platziert, wenn man die
anhaltenden Reaktionen auf philosophische Masami
so erkennt, die ihr Punkt sind oder  Es gab eigentlich keine,
dass Christine es darauf anlegt, dass
man keine Frauen präsentieren sollte  als
antithetisch zum philosophischen Leben
oder zum wissenschaftlichen Leben, weil
wir uns tatsächlich Beispiele von Frauen vorstellen können,
die mit dem großen Philosophen Seneca
oder Sokrates verheiratet waren, und im Allgemeinen sollten wir
Frauen als irgendwie schädlich für das
Gedeihen von Männern ansehen, es gibt gute Frauen,
die  die nicht verheiratet waren die gejagt wurden oder
asketen es gab auch gute verdienste bei
frauen die verheiratet waren und die
ihre männer unterstützten und ihnen vielleicht tatsächlich halfen
philosophen zu werden es ist eine wirklich
interessante idee es ist auch interessant
dass sie will dass wir die idee ernst nehmen
das die  Frauen selbst sollten
gebildet sein, also, wenn Sie das wollen, denke ich, wird ihr
Rat sein, wenn Sie eine
Gelehrte werden wollen, wenn Sie eine Philosophin werden wollen,
denke ich, in Ihrem eigenen Recht und
Sie ein Mann sind, sollten Sie eine
gelehrte Frau heiraten  man sollte eine
gebildete Frau wie Christine selbst heiraten
und dies nimmt eigentlich
frühneuzeitliche Diskussionen in feministischer
Tradition vorweg, etwa in Mary
Wollstonecraft w  ho schrieb eine Arbeit
genau zu dieser Frage über die
Bildung von Frauen und eines ihrer
Hauptargumente dort ist, dass es manueller
Vorteil ist, mit gebildeten Frauen verheiratet zu sein
, um auf die Romantik der Rose zurückzukommen, die
ich zuvor gesagt habe, eines der Dinge
, die die Verteidiger von  Die Rose-Frage
ist diese Idee, dass John Demoon ein Frauenhasser ist,
nur weil er einige
dieser Charaktereigenschaften hat,
und eigentlich ist das ziemlich interessant,
weil angesichts der literarischen
Sensibilität dieser Verteidiger ihr Instinkt
eigentlich nicht ist, einfach auf
Christine zurückzukommen  Frauenfeindlichere Argumente
ihre Strategie ist zu sagen, eigentlich
Zhang Demoon identifiziert sie mit dem, was
seine Charaktere sagen, weil dies ein
literarisches Werk ist und in einem literarischen Werk nicht
alles, was jeder sagt,
Ausdruck der eigenen Meinung des Autors ist
und sie es sogar versuchen  Machen Sie daraus
, was in der Romanze der
Rosen geschah, die davor gewarnt
wurden, ein
dummes Selbst zu sein und so  Alles in der
Romantik der Rose ist nur ein Weg
, den Liebhaber davon zu überzeugen, dem Verlangen nicht nachzugeben,
so genau das Gegenteil
von dem, was Christine gesagt hat, vielleicht hat sich John
Diamond verzehrt,
also hier ist ein Beispiel für diese Art von
Reaktion  schreibt John DeMarco zur
Verteidigung der Rose, so sagt er, dass die
Kritiker der Rose weder
die Vielfalt der Charaktere unterscheiden noch
bemerken, durch welche Leidenschaften sie
motiviert sind, mit welchen Emotionen sie
ausgestattet sind oder zu welchem Zweck in einem Po
izisten in was  Kontext, warum sie
sprechen, noch denken sie, dass dieser
Lehrer auf dem Mond genau
die Rolle eines Satirikers einnimmt,
wodurch viele Dinge erlaubt sind
, die anderen Autoren verboten sind, und ich denke,
das bringt uns tatsächlich zu einem
interessanten philosophischen Thema  in der
ästhetik und philosophie der literatur
, was denken wir also über ein literarisches
werk oder allgemein ein künstlerisches werk
könnte zum beispiel ein film sein, wo
eine figur erlaubt ist  etwas zu sagen
, das wirklich widerwärtig ist, denken wir
, dass das in Ordnung ist, weil der
Autor normalerweise mit den verwendeten Charakteren identifiziert wird.
Glauben wir, dass der Autor
immer für
alles, was die Charaktere sagen, entflammbar sein wird, macht
es einen großen Unterschied, wenn wir es tun
Äußere Gründe zu glauben, dass der
Autor einverstanden ist, sagen die sexistischen oder
rassistischen Dinge, die die Figur im Film sagt.
Ich meine, Sie könnten zum
Beispiel einen modernen Filmregisseur gegenüberstellen,
der einen Film wie 12 Jahre lang zum Sklaven macht,
wo es offensichtlich gibt  einige
rassistische Charaktere darin, die rassistische Dinge sagen,
aber es ist sehr klar, dass der
Filmregisseur kein Rassist ist und eine
sehr negative Einstellung zur Sklaverei hat
und versucht, es zu zeigen, also sind diese
Charaktere böse, die sich sehr von denen
unterscheiden, die von einem gemacht wurden  rassistisch, in
dem rassistische Gefühle
mit Zustimmung des Regisseurs, aber
die Kritiker der Rose
John the Moon nicht vom Haken lassen wollen und
einer der Verbündeten von sind  Christine entwirft eine
Person namens John Gets on, der
Kanzler an der Universität von Paris war,
wies diese Art der Verteidigung der
Rose gerade ab, indem er sagte, dies sei eine zu geringe
Verteidigung für einen so großartigen Kunden. Ich frage
Sie, ob sich jemand zum
Gegner des Königs erklärt hat  von Frankreich und die
Verwendung dieses Namens in dieser Identität, die
mit diesem Namen Krieg geführt hat, bewahrt ihn
davor, ein Verräter zu sein und den Tod zu erleiden, den
Sie
schuldeten  wie diese Fehler gegen das
Christentum sein werden, wird er dafür entschuldigt
werden,
also ist der Punkt, dass es einige Dinge gibt, die
man nicht einmal im
Kontext eines literarischen Werks sagen kann, und ich denke, das ist
tatsächlich ein wirklich interessanter Fall, in dem
unsere ästhetischen und  literarische Sensibilitäten
liegen wahrscheinlich bei den Verteidigern der
Rose, obwohl wir uns instinktiv auf die Seite
von Christine und Jean Goss stellen, weil
wir die Frauenfeindlichkeit der Rosen nicht mögen,
also würden wir es wahrscheinlich tun  Ich möchte sagen, dass
Christine und Jean Breslin in der
Tat ein bisschen zu naiv oder
oberflächlich sind, wenn sie das Gedicht lesen
, obwohl wir offensichtlich
der Art von politischer oder sozialer
Agenda hinter ihrer Kritik zustimmen wollen, und deshalb
gibt es eine Art interessant  Wenn
unsere ästhetischen Sensibilitäten auf der
einen Seite liegen mögen, unsere politischen Sensibilitäten
jedoch ethische Sensibilitäten eindeutig auf
der anderen Seite liegen, ist dies eine wirklich interessante
Debatte, die uns so ziemlich zum
Ende dieser Vortragsreihe bringt, dass es
das Letzte ist, worüber ich sprechen wollte  über,
aber ich möchte nicht das letzte Wort haben
und in dieser Reihe von Vorträgen über
Frauen Frauen möchte ich lieber, dass eine Frau
das letzte Wort hat, also werde ich diesen letzten Vortrag beenden,
indem ich Ihnen danke, dass Sie sich mir angeschlossen haben. Ich
hoffe, es hat Ihnen gefallen  Ich hoffe, du lernst
etwas und findest sie lustig und
interessant, und ich möchte damit abschließen
, dir vorzulesen,
was meine Lieblingspassage von Christina
Design ist, findet es nicht so schlau, dass sie eine
sagt  Eines Tages kritisierte ein Mann meinen Wunsch
nach Wissen und sagte, dass es
für eine Frau unangebracht sei, etwas zu
lernen, da es so selten sei, worauf ich
antwortete, dass es
für einen Mann noch weniger angemessen sei, unwissend zu sein, da dies so
üblich sei